welcome to this video playing tactic guy
from Israel mostly those guys play don't
play tactica at all with names like that
ok we have a Evan Italian game we went
for a very quick Bishop to g5 on
interesting ok yeah I'm curious how
where does he put it they put the king
jam probably going to cancel short for
me it's now difficult to Castle long in
this situation or what can i play a five
really could be interesting yeah why not
this will get me get me maybe the c5
square like 96 coming to oh wow really
and I'm not going G I can go 25 m come
on then take on d5 had some very weird
stuff isn't it okay then grab the space
in okay so going to go into push this
it looks very dangerous for what if g4
is coming I know I have the King on yet
but yeah this is not not so important I
guess okay this needs to be played
anyway and yeah okay Angie three winning
winning the bishop okay he will get
something back with a six but so should
be should be very good um I can even
take twice there I mean you cannot go
rookie one pass I'm going to take on F
to check out okay come on let's not be
too too sophisticated about it just
returned one piece and I've got two
pieces at the moment two extra pieces
okay should I take f7 I guess it's
probably easiest and now f3 maybe two to
break through yeah let's not let's not
spend ages am this is probably the win
anyway Queen takes Queen txg takes
Bishop h3 and then I can get get d 50 f3
whatever i'm going to go in to
breakthrough
white resigns yep Bishop g5 was was a
strange move I mean I don't know I I
like like here but it's probably nothing
special going on yeah compute this about
equal 0.34 white yeah something like
castles 96's is normal and here i can
really just do that with a big advantage
yeah white bishop is especially
especially I'm offside him this c4 and
therefore yeah on g4 immediately ok this
has given us not okay now it goes now
the engine switches to a black advantage
after that black wins yeah but ok it was
them trying to to muddy the waters him
yam and Bishop f5 is also good but f
three years is rather convincing he must
take worth the Queen and here i thought
just taking digs and now this one to get
to get a free mature being pretty
convincing its its material and i still
have the attack on the king yes no no we
account the plane yeah but should be
five was awesome was a big mistake okay
thanks for watching